[Music]
and juicy smolier big fan big fan
do you watch empire uh
power or empire empire right i love
he's my favorite character uh was
sentenced to five months in jail for
falsely claiming he was a victim of a
hate crime but literally one hour ago he
walked out of jail and still faces an
uncertain future
what why no why is he walking out of
jail so he walked out of chicago jail
after serving six days
less than a week dude yeah uh from
what's uh in terms of uh how did this
even [ __ ] i'm just reading it's news
that just came out right now to be
honest we're gonna do just like the
covering the article in general and then
i just yeah and then i just googled it
and it's like he just walked out of jail
like what the [ __ ] is that's pretty
crazy
um so the former star of the tv show
empire was sentenced last week to 150
days in jail plus probation and a fine
after a jury found him guilty of lying
to police about being a victim of a
racist anti-gay attack in downtown
chicago in 2019. his release late
wednesday came hours after an uh apolog
how do you pronounce that appalachian
tell it there it is appellate uh uh
ordered he could go free during the
appeal process which wouldn't be
completed before sommelier uh had served
his full sentence
juicy sommelier did it because of the uh
what is it the plea or whatever where
they release him and now pending the
appeal yeah and then now now
they determine whether he goes back in
or not yeah but it's a it's an
undisclosed and uncertain amount of time
you know it's so funny dude so i thought
this was an absolute
joke right and then um i saw the los
angeles blm saying free smolier right
and i was like no the actual blm
instagram was promoting that and when
you look into the comments everybody
like a hundred percent of people were
like okay you have time to delete this
right now this is a bad look
everybody dude this one is a little bit
of a stretch i can't stand by this like
the comments were [ __ ] hilarious it's
pretty [ __ ] funny but like this one
we can't back up you know and it's like
because he's the first black man in
history to commit a hate crime on
himself yeah that's so he's still
denying it too which is crazy he's
denying that he did it he's he's
mentally ill or something dude the
entire time he's held to his truth that
he had not done that and um it was an
actual attack yeah actually believes him
too right i don't know or they
politically need to support him somehow
yeah yeah yeah well i believe that
there's a group that does believe that
no one should be in jail period
so they don't believe in the jail
process at all and i think a little bit
of that crept into the republic
where they don't really believe in
criminal punishment they believe in
rehabilitation and all these other
things and so uh with that in mind that
specific subset of believers think that
him being in jail in the first place no
one should be in jail
what do they believe in if you rape
someone you take them to the park or
what like
but
the most logical like with their
reasoning is probably like you know you
need to rehabilitate these people and
not criminalize them what about when
someone fakes
a racial hate crime that's probably a
psychological issue you know what do you
do with that but holds true to their
entire story some people think social
workers can fix anything
i think it'd be hilarious to just charge
him with a hate crime on himself
because that's what he essentially did i
think it sucks for for people to always
be like no man social workers should
handle it but like what if social
workers don't want to handle that one
they usually don't they usually don't
yeah the people that are they yeah like
they
like jill's sisters a social worker and
you know some of the environments that
she has to go into she's like i'm not
walking until the cops are here it's
like really big because it can get crazy
real fast you know under the conditions
of the sentence imposed by cook county
judge james lynn smallett must now serve
the 30-month probation though he may
leave the state and travel without
restrictions so he's free that means he
could travel to places like los angeles
and new york to try to resurrect his
career so nothing's gonna happen to him
for what he did i feel like what he did
he should go to jail for at least a year
bro like you can't [ __ ] is that too
harsh
if you think about what he did right
what that does is it
basically creates more race tensions in
this country
that it's already not good that's what
people are saying that he's trying to
start a race war that's what the judge
said yeah that's crazy man for what so
you get some clout yeah
that's why the judge would was like nah
dude because you're stoking a really
sensitive like fire
at that specific time like the cause
needs more of that
just wait i'm sure something like that's
going to happen anyway you know what i
mean like and maybe somebody already
knows that slips through exactly yeah he
also just like almost discredited all
the like work that black activists have
done
because like when you have a guy that's
doing this stuff it's like well then
people go how many other black people
are actually committing fake hate crimes
on themselves and reporting it after
this incident you know and it's not just
black right it's also like um because
he's also gay like that there's a whole
anti-gay element uh involved as well so
he tried to stack everything like black
gay everything man yeah and here's the
thing
um
during the trial smallet testified that
i've lost my livelihood because of the
charges against him as you should losing
his role on empire but he has since
worked behind the scenes writing
directing and producing a film called
b-boy blues no way maybe you could get a
roll there that recently won apparently
the fan favorite narrative feature award
in the american black film festival how
can we guys gonna see this movie i don't
think it's the same b-boy but okay and
then uh while work in front of the
camera may be difficult to find smaller
could get opportunities working behind
the scenes particularly because he has a
sister and other family members with
successful careers in the industry well
i mean people still got to eat so i
guess it's a little bit of a stretch to
kind of be like well you shouldn't even
be able to work because people all got
to eat but at the same time well i think
there's a difference between that and uh
hey you had a 150-day sentence actually
it's six days go back to work yeah
that's true he needed yeah he there's
there's absolutely if he did his time
and he came back out he started his
career back up i think that's different
but like trying to like fake something
potentially starting a race war i think
you need to like pay your time six days
back what's the poetic justice there's
guys with duis that go in for longer
than six days you guys are smoking weed
in other states besides california jail
for like 10 years for their life like 30
years
that's so true i mean i know i know part
of the argument is that they don't think
he should be in jail because it just
doesn't i guess he's not like a violent
offender like you're not protecting
society from him being in prison
technically it's what they're saying are
you gonna fake a bunch of other [ __ ]
gets beat up for real though do you
think that will probably happen i think
what if he goes cries
that's poetic justice that would really
suck if that happened because he's not
in a position to like tell on anyone now
this letter from blm said that uh black
lives matter stands in strong support of
an alternative to incarceration sentence
for justice mollet we applaud your
long-held practice of imposing
alternatives to incarceration sentences
for virtually all class four felonies
such as mr smalletts and encourage you
to continue this practice in this case
so i mean it's just i think it's funny
to see a picture of him and says freeze
moliere right because it's like come on
should we free him but then the
sentiment yeah it's there's this whole
movement going on right now where people
want to model like a scandinavian model
of uh you know reform which is like they
have a great rehabilitation
program where
people that do commit crimes have a huge
chance of not relapsing and going back
to jail and then they get back into the
community and i think they want to do
that here but i'm like dude have you
seen those comparisons where like
someone will always say no look look at
scandinavia look at norway look at all
these places and then someone always
goes you know those are predominantly
white countries they don't let anybody
in yeah it's like you can't base a
country's happiness
they're all white man like of course
they're fine of course they're happy
that's the key
everybody looks the same you can't
compare it because it's like no you
can't one culture once one understanding
low population they also have a lot of
income for the size of what they are
yeah it's like there's so many factors
to consider you can't just be like
planet because i could just be like well
look at china
[Laughter]
like that is a political stance look at
china you know like that's
look at papua new guinea
they can do it they get along just fine
it's like a different [ __ ] country
dude
well madagascar car can happen you know
like the [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] now
more countries
more hits more hits now that's what i
call good governments volume one
[Laughter]
yeah i want to see people see
free uh cain velasquez
no i don't think so he shouldn't be free
no he needs to be free man what he did
was disgusting bro he was protecting his
disgusting what you said last time yeah
dude i'm gonna free his i'm a big fan of
kane but that's sad that you see like a
guy like if we're gonna obviously
completely different
uh
crimes right but you see you think of a
guy like cain velasquez who's just like
he's probably gonna be in jail for the
next like 10 15 years do you think all
right this is maybe i'm gonna fake
anything i didn't say anything you think
that no matter what no matter what okay
unpopular probably uh if let's say um
i'm gonna be extreme for the sake of the
conversation if every crime was
punishable by death every holy [ __ ] and
even if like you like a hate crime on
yourself something where you're trying
to protect your your daughter's dignity
to actually stealing or whatever of
course in every case by case maybe it's
like really like that's [ __ ] up that
person didn't deserve died but do you
think after a while
eventually because of something so
ferocious and extreme there may be like
enough of like a
hive mentality to not do anything
criminal well that would be demolition
man the movie yeah and that was a good
movie there it is i'm a writer
you're you're plugging your smallest
sister hit me up
that system will only work if it's
not controlled by people
because obviously like
immediately what i would think is well
how do i become the decision maker of
who dies
so if i'm the judge or if i'm the ruling
class party then i can say i don't like
nick that much you know he's kind of
like weird
there's other guys here hey nick like
i think you committed a crime and then
it's like right he saw it i saw it
yesterday i think he did yeah i know
this is a joke but i feel like kind of
attacked her no it's not it's kind of
[ __ ] up but that's literally a witch
hunt it's just another case for bitcoin
yeah i just got nervous i was like no i
didn't do anything i didn't do any crime
all right fair enough then looks like
nobody's dying today it's kind of weird
because like when you when you see the
jesse smallhead stuff and you're like it
i don't know if everybody feels this way
but like when i see somebody like
being led out of jail for some something
they actually did all i feel is like all
the [ __ ] that i did that i didn't get
off like i got in trouble and i did my
[ __ ] thing
it makes me just have like less empathy
for someone else i'm just like dude i
[ __ ] get in trouble all the time like
it's like when you get a parking ticket
yeah and there's a [ __ ] homeless
trailer parked in front of your car
that's been there two years they get
zero tickets i'm getting this ticket
really like it just makes you every
thursday because of street sweeping you
have more animosity for this [ __ ]
trailer but then like if you're trying
to live a good life and you don't
generally you know profit off crime then
when you just see somebody get off for
any reason it you don't have like a go
easy on them thing it kind of also makes
me go like why am i following the rules
yeah these guys are all getting away
we're just gonna start stealing stuff
bro honestly
why am i being such a good citizen like
i'm not really a like i'm not a free my
homie kind of guy because i'm not in the
[ __ ] crime scene again like i don't
do that [ __ ] so i got a ticket for
jaywalking well you should have because
i was pasadena
you